what's going on you guys it's Lord ad
here and King daveid coming at you this
is our first spoiler cast like this you
know these going to be a new type of
program that we put in the members and
and prron where me and King are just
going to you know give our in depth
conversation when it comes to video
games we're going to have one for
Spider-Man I believe our next one's
going to be Mario wonders I'm not quite
sure yet but I've been playing through
that so it's King uh you know I've been
told that it's got Co-op I don't know
we'll see uh so we we'll go into that
but today is about
Spider-Man 2 you know this has been a
highly anticipated PlayStation exclusive
and uh me and King have both beat it he
is 100% of it I don't do that what what
they do they call that Platinum dick
yeah I don't do that all right uh that
that I I I am not people's Aaron boys
and if PlayStation wants King to be an
Aaron boy King can be an Aaron boy well
well listen let me tell you something
I'm not even going to front um for those
Spider-Man games I'm all about that like
getting those suits and that stuff like
that and I like the missions I like the
stuff um uh you know what's crazy this
is the only type of games that I do that
with I don't do that with um Ragnarok I
didn't do it with God of War uh but the
Spider-Man games all of them I've done
the same EXA same exact thing yeah see I
I'm more of a I got to either enjoy it
or they got to tell me why I'm going get
up front you know and the suits don't do
that for me it's like you know you
you're more of a comic book head I'm not
there so they don't really grab me with
that they're like yo we give you these
suits I'm cool with the original I don't
care and disgusting and then especially
after I
got the Venom Suit the anti-venom suit I
was this one looks this looks fly you
ain't gonna get me to get out the house
I I I love how like when you look at the
the suit like when there's nothing
around I like to stand and look at the
suits and you see the suit
moving um and the the multi-layer and
the multi-dimensions and the textures it
looks really good it looked like how I
thought the comic
books coming to life would look and and
they did a real good job I love what
Sucker Punch has done so you know
normally we talk about story first
because I feel like story in a regular
review is the thing you can't expand on
the most but this is a spoilercast we
could talk about that we can break it
down spoil the hell out of that so I
want to say that for a little bit
towards the end of the show this going
be like a 30 45 minute show uh so what I
want to talk about is the atmosphere of
the game King you know did you feel like
they did a better job building uh New
York I'm not the biggest familiar person
with New York the entire area new New
Jersey's New York to me New York is New
York to me everything is New York to me
there's no there's no New Jersey New
York that's this separated everything is
New York to me I don't know what's in
this game what's not in this game
everything is New York to me all right
so T to you uh you you you playing the
game you wouldn't know if something's
out of place you wouldn't know if um
they did they was inaccurate with some
of the landmarks uh for the most part
since 2018 they've captured all the
landmarks they've captured all the
streets they have the map of New York
City so it's very hard to uh mess up the
map of New York City and in this day and
age we have Google Maps so they they
pretty much have the the map of New York
City down pack what is that bottom right
because if am I correct that wasn't in
the original 2018 no you're talking
about Queens yeah so that was Queens
they put all yeah do they put all of
Queens in here or is it just no no
queens is way bigger than that is they
you know they didn't put all of Brooklyn
they put parts of queens and parts of
Brooklyn is that new content yes all
right so how do you feel like they you
know obviously they can't make this how
it would actually be there's way more
people in New York then they can
realistically fit on the screen how did
you feel like they captured New York in
general the density yeah the density of
New York City is there like e even with
the people um New York city streets
aren't really super populated unless
you're like going to the Bronx or um
something like that in the outskirts uh
it's um it was very densely populated as
far as as for what the game can give you
because you're asking the game to give
you raid Trac and your ACC in the game
to give you all types of things uh from
the the skyscrapers to how tall they are
to how uh tightly packed the city is I I
thought they did a fantastic job in
capturing the atmosphere of new New York
City to hustle and bustle you hear the
sounds you see the pigeons you see
people moving if they're walking they on
bikes then cars you had different levels
of cars you had uh trucks you you had
regular Vehicles you had construction
workers on some points the so the game
did capture the atmosphere of New York
City and they've set that tone since uh
2018 so I didn't I didn't think that
they would miss that here okay see the
reason I'm asking you is because I don't
know you know like I said everything in
there's New York to me everything uh so
I wanted you know for our viewers
especially people like me that's not in
that uh that's not in that area I wanted
like you know did they genuinely capture
the Phil of New York right right yeah
they did without a doubt definitely 100%
so the combat in this game changed a
little bit from
2018 uh they kind kind of went I I feel
like they they centered 2018 around the
gadgets like a lot of the game was
centered around gadgets sent around uh
you know uh the the the dodging button
they did add a Parry system on here and
they Stripped Away a lot of the gadgets
so I want your opinion on that and they
replaced them with you know combo
attacks where it's like you know you use
the metal suit that's that the Skeleton
thing whatever that thing's called for
Spider-Man spider leg yeah spider legs
and Miles has not only Venom abilities
but electric abilities as well I don't
know if they're the considered the same
thing they the same thing yeah but they
look like they look different colors so
I felt like they were you know maybe
more a more potent Venom with the
electric attacks but they did look
different to me so maybe you can explain
that as well so the things that I would
like from you is how did you feel about
taking the gadgets on and the changes
they made to to Miles and uh Peter when
it comes to that particular Point well
the combat is a natural Evolution from
2018 so 2018 was a trial and era type of
thing and they tried to use a lot of
whatever you know um Spider-Man gadgets
he does have so they tried to use that
and the Miles Morales game uh his Venom
abilities they I think the color palet
in the Miles Morales game was a little
bit different only because they wanted
to show the richness and the texture of
that world so
if if you go back to the Miles Morales
game the purples really pop more the
colors really pop in that game more so
than they do in the Spider-Man game the
Spider-Man game was a little bit muted
uh when it came to the colors Miles
Morales colors was off the charts to me
and it's still is I'mma probably go back
and check that today um and then they
tried to Mel the to hair so what you did
get with um they toned down how miles's
uh electricity look by giving giving it
a natural based color uh because I I
don't think that that color would be
would work well without with how much
activity is on the screen so they had to
do that change the color there uh the
combo system that they use between each
other is fantastic what I did notice is
between both characters miles is faster
miles is faster and more explosive than
Peter is I feel like miles is more
diverse uh more versatile as well like
you know for the most part like until
you get the Venom suit I felt like Peter
was kind of O underwhelming like he yeah
he he felt that way and I felt like the
skeleton the spider skeleton that didn't
do nothing for me like once once you got
the Venom suit and you using the Venom
abilities like that those legs could go
somewhere like oh so you talking about
okay the spider legs all right so that
was to give
him the a little bit of diversity right
because they wanted to build you up to
Spider-Man if if if you notice
throughout the game before he even got
to the Venom symbiot Suit he
was handling
issues a little bit more strenuous than
Milwood Milwood had handled issues with
a little bit more Vigor he can take out
teams of people a little bit more faster
uh Spider-Man himself Peter himself had
issues until he got the Venom suit and
that's why he felt that it it made him a
better uh Spider-Man but also his move
set expanded when you went down to his
move set after he got that set that suit
his move set opened up and I think they
purposely limited him early on in the
game uh to show you when you got this
the the symbat suit how more powerful he
was kind of like to
show why he kind of like obviously you
know we'll get more into the personality
changes that happened when the symia
took over Peter uh but it it to show you
more of that Evolution it's like you
know cuz if anything you know I'm I'm
looking um I'm playing Persona 4 right
now I just be five and the way they get
their Persona is they like pretty much
they they
accept the the the thoughts in their
head that they don't want to accept like
right jealousy you know okay you you
love your friend but at the same time
you're jealous of them they have to
accept that to get that power so like to
me like
Peter
is he's sure of himself but in the back
of his mind he's he he's unsure and he's
like look I'm doing all these things and
I'm doubting myself too much but I'm not
I'm not talking about it a lot and then
to me when the simpo took over those
those opinions
were harder to conceal and he said them
more yeah well the thing about it is uh
in the com comic
book pet Spider-Man's base uh Power set
is 10 tons he can lift 10 tons right so
when he got the symbat suit he was able
to lift 25 tons right so that's a
drastic uh Improvement to his base power
level over double yeah so his base over
he's way stronger then he became faster
so in com comic book wise does he ever
get to that point again without the suit
or is it just no no the suit augments
him the suit the suit that's that's why
the suit was so important to him early
on and the suit lasted with him for a
long time the suit lasted with him for
like four years four or five years um oh
in the comics yeah in the comic he had
that he had that black suit that long
yeah he he had that suit for a while
yeah so um and because they was doing a
story arc the story arc was longer than
what the the game is the game is can't
stretch you know multiple video games uh
to told the story arc so they told the
story arc in a condensed uh form but uh
as far as what it did to him it enhanced
him in every way his Spider Sense was
faster his reaction times was faster he
was running on pure adrenaline what the
symbiot did was link into his
neurological system and his adrenaline
and allow him to pump full adrenaline at
all times so that's why he was so tired
and so sleepy because he will burn his
adrenaline
100% so pretty much the symbiot doesn't
make you stronger naturally it just
makes you tap into your entire body
infrastructure to be stronger correct
well it does but it also makes you
stronger okay you see because the
symbiot naturally itself is a stronger
entity than um Parker by himself because
when the any symbiot attaches itself to
a normal human it takes on and I'll
explain why of when it became Venom it
still had the Spider-Man like properties
right uh
because that it it's it copied and
mimicked that and it became part of its
DNA so that's why some of the stuff that
they were talking about inside the game
held true throughout so that's why I I
liked what the
the game was talking about so yeah the
the the symbiot itself is a stronger
entity than an average human so the fact
that it latched itself on to Peter
because it found Peter more alluring
because he was stronger than the average
human that it came in contact with so
after it found that and then it found
that the level of adrenaline it was able
to P push it it was it wanted to bond
and stay with him because it found as a
better host I I get what you're saying
like you know in in the in the game it
it latches on to Harry first but he's
just a regular actually crippled human
before he latched onto but not only is
he going on to a healthy person he's
also going on to someone that has been
Genetically Enhanced by a spider bite
and when when you pump an adrenaline
through his body his body can handle it
right and he's at Peak physical form
he's at Absolute Peak physical form
Spider-Man and Captain America are Peak
Physical humans and same thing with
black
panther okay okay they I was very
interested on that you know I I
personally feel like you know the world
was very livid it was very live I I felt
like the activities was okay now I know
you did all of them I I did some of them
I I like the the M Mysterio ones I don't
know was there a fight with Mysterio yes
so I completed all of it and you get to
the last uh chapter of it and then you
find out that it really wasn't Mysterio
himself it was his his uh cohorts his uh
employees that those people that you
think those two girls that you think
that is his employees they're not his
employees actually they hijacked his
Tech and put all these bugs inside his
Tech and locked Mysterio up in a closet
and it was kind of crazy and they used
his Pana inside uh the mysterium that's
across uh the board and you I think it's
like eight to 10 of them that you got to
do but they're really cool and some of
them have different objectives for you
to to complete them like knock people
off the ledge or only score finishing
moves stuff like that or yank people to
you it it's it's really cool see I enjoy
the combat but not enough to do stuff
like that you know what I'm say it was
just like it was a cool combat but to me
it didn't really like I personally like
the Arkham combats better I I think
those more they feel they feel better
they feel like I'm actually hitting
stuff like sometimes I felt like
Spider-Man is way stronger than Batman
but he ain't putting the output that I
felt when I was Batman in Arkham like
when I hit someone in Arkham I feel like
I hit that person like I feel like they
did damage the visceral nature of Batman
is it's more bone breaking more up close
more visceral combat Spider-Man is
remember you also got to remember this
is Disney he holds back yeah yeah he
he's holding back he's fighting regular
street thugs if if he hit a street Thug
his full strength he would punch them
across like Street well they they they
they said that inside the game remember
when he was fighting Venom he said I
don't have to hold back oh no matter of
fact it wasn't Venom it was robots when
he started fighting the robots he said
good I can let go and use all my power
so that's that's that's the nature of
Spider-Man he's always holding back okay
and that was my uh opinion on that
matter I I think the I I like the side
activities that lead up to like a last
chapter thing I think flame because I
was told the flame had like some really
good stuff on there oh so then you did
you you teamed up with wraith you saw
her again uh that's a interesting
character that they put in there so you
got the rafe costume right yeah all
right so see that's what I'm talking
about if you did the mysterium you would
have got the Mysterio costume the
Mysterio costume look crazy dope uh it's
just the costumes didn't do not like I
don't think I literally unlocked any of
them like well you know 2018 costumes
did stuff yeah yeah they they did extra
stuff but they for some reason they took
all that out I don't know why they did
that uh maybe it was just adding on to
the development cycle maybe it was just
hard to balance all those suits that's
what it is the balance was there more
suits in this one than there was in 28
18 or was about to I have to go back and
check um I didn't like the fact that I
had to pay for these suits because if I
didn't get the premium the premium one
has at least eight four at the bottom
four or five no it's eight it's like
eight of them oh okay yeah so um I
didn't use any of that's why I I use all
of them
I what I the only time my costume
changed is when my costume change in the
story you're ridiculous I hate it when
they forc me to use the van suit did
change miles with like his hair showing
I didn't like the look of that one for
some reason I went back to his old
costume cuz I thought it was cheesy yeah
I thought that one looked better in
general yeah uh so all right
let's let's talk about the so I'm
looking for the atmosphere changing uh
once Venom is introduced into the game
he kind of changes the entire game I'mma
be real with you King I didn't know
Venom was like this I didn't know he
rolled like this I've only seen Venom in
the Spider-Man TV shows here and there
and I didn't really watch those like
crazy like I thought he was just a like
a Symbio thing that latches on to people
I didn't know he could do the things
that's in this game okay it blew my mind
like maybe you can like clarify or but
when I saw this stuff I was like oh this
is different Venom I ain't never seen
this Venom like all right so what they
did was they read all the books and they
took all of them and and made a cohesive
story that made sense right so they took
maximum uh Venom they took the maximum
carage storyline they took the symbiots
story line they took the null
storyline and they wo all of them
together so that meteorite that's there
that metor right is true but it comes
from his planet where there's a planet
of
and what happened is null he is uh the
first symbiot and he has the symbiot uh
sword he is like the Omega and they all
link to him Venom is a rogue that is
broke away from the hive mind so and
real quick like I did a little research
in the past on this individual you're
talking about with the sword he's one of
the strongest people in MCU correct yes
yes okay okay so and Eddie Brock kills
him all right so uh it gets to a point
where that storyline comes to a close
but you saw that storyline being here
because what what the symbiots do
they're kind of like aliens from the
movie Aliens they go to planets and they
take over and all that goo and stuff
that you do see actually starts to take
uh Fester all over the place they did
this at an accelerated rate Venom is not
able to do that in his base form the
same form that you
that's why it was tripping me out
because I've never seen him do stuff
like that now I would assume the the
leader of all the symbiots he could do
that kind of stuff but they made Venom
that in this game okay you see that's
why he was able to make scream um make
uh Carnage make um was Carnage in this
game well I'm explaining that too when
did you finish the Flames side story
line I did the majority of it I don't
think I all right you got to finish it
when you finish it is a reason why flame
is um doing all the stuff that he does
cuz it's the end game to it and he gets
to his end game and this a spoiler cast
he gets to a piece of the the the
symbiot because the symia came and it
broke it off into a couple of pieces and
O Corp still had that one piece there
they hijacked the train and got it
Flames one of his aliases is Cletus
Cassidy Cletus Cassidy is um is
Whatchamacallit is uh Carnage in in the
comic books right is totally different
character they melded the two characters
because that character uh flame is
disillusion cult-like
environment and he's able to kill
without remorse and he was trying to he
set Spider-Man on fire oh my God yeah
like he poured gasoline all over his
body and set him on
fire the game shows different aspects
and they left no stone unturned when it
came to story they gave you every story
line in Venom's history all in this one
game do you think that was a mistake
maybe they should have like stuck to the
origins of Venom and then expanded going
forward maybe in a DLC cuz to
me I don't know I I didn't do the entire
flame thing but to me they kind of like
killed this whole aspect that they could
have tapped into in the future or do you
think they'll go back to it no the thing
is when they did the DLC in Spider-Man
2018 and they had the black cat stuff
and they had Tombstone stuff Tombstone
is hair in this game and they even
expounded on that on on the tombstone
stuff and and showed that he didn't go
back to a life of crime because you know
Spider-Man sent him and he he was
rehabilitated this is an older Peter
so I don't think the way that they
killing off characters and you know they
killed off uh vulture they killed them
off like crazy but and this is what I I
saw people complaining about oh they
they're killing off the characters they
won't build the world because
everybody's expecting them to build this
world where where the enemies keep
coming back and Spider-Man keeps uh
fighting them in the real world
characters die yeah
yeah they're just telling a story arc
and I feel like if they are building
like a universe in the in PlayStation
when it comes to MCU like they're not
going to just fight Spiderman villains
like right they're going to fight
everybody else Wolverine if he comes in
because they've already confirmed
they're part of the same universe you
didn't see the Wolverine suit in Miles
Morales no I saw saw Wolverine one the
white uh the White Ranger one that was
no but he has different colors he has
the green one he has all all of them he
has the Japanese Power Ranger one
because when you get out the when you
get the DLC I mean the um the the the
what is that the extended copy or
whatever the the deluxe copy he has that
one he has the the Japanese uh Power
Ranger suit and then you get out the
American Power Ranger suit when you
unlock it that's interesting it's
interesting all right let's let's get
let's get to the meat potatoes man
the story of Spider-Man 2 you know I
think we could did you expect Venom to
be the last boss or did you think they
would throw you a couple curve balls or
did you think that maybe you would team
up with Venom to fight something or
because I know in the past like
Spider-Man and Venom have teamed up
multiple times like you're let get give
me what you kind of expected them to go
in this direction and then we'll talk
about the actual story that Spider-Man
turned out to be I knew Venom at the end
of the day would be his ultimate uh
enemy I I I I know that from the books
so for them to waste that opportunity on
having them team up which they did to
some extent and and I'll expound on that
when we go to uh when you want to get to
that part but um they did to some extent
but no my expectations of it it played
out how I expected it to play out yeah
um
that's that's pretty much how I expected
it what what I will say is I was really
feeling the different tone change of
Peter when he had that suit on like like
I like I like the the Mary Jane fight
when she became scream and she was
sitting there she she was talking all
this first off I didn't like how I did
feel like they were they were like
taking a lot of the shine away from from
from uh from Peter
it's like even when they were arguing
back and forth between scream and Peter
it's just like you're literally
complaining about stuff that he has no
control over that's you oh then he can't
hold a job and that yeah the mortgage is
Du and that all this other stuff yeah
what's funny is at the beginning she
offered to pay the mortgage and he said
I won't take your money so you're not
paying the
mortgage what are you bitching about
like it that was inner thoughts of how
to get under his skin so I understood
that fight that fight was really good
and you know Peter stayed you know true
uh because you know he loves her um it
it was really interesting dialogue
though like so you do know that Cletus
Carnage made them no I didn't know that
yeah Carnage made them those those
symbat scream and all that other stuff
and the com to my
knowledge the parents and The Offspring
hate each other every time yes so like
cage came from Venom he hates Venom and
so that mean could does venom work with
Scream is that same hatred towards later
ends of the symbium or is it just the
father and the uh in it's just the the
parent and the kid which is is hilarious
I it's hilarious yeah so that that was
my biggest thing I didn't know who
scream was I'm going be real with you
there was multiple times in this but you
knew she was different when you saw her
compared she had other she had a health
bar that's one biggest giveaway and two
she didn't look she had long hair like a
long like wasn't hair but yeah I first
thing I did is I paused and I googled
that [__] I was like scream got to be
real like this this person is
too and apparently what I saw she hasn't
even really been married Jane in the
actual show she was never married Jane
yeah they kind of just threw that at did
do they needed that so you you agree
with that decision well it fits in line
with the story a lot of the stuff that
they were saying in here is not Harry
has never been Venom oh uh what's funny
is I remember rumors that Harry might be
Venom before the game came out because
uh there was rumors that that Craven
would be Venom and I and I think Craven
has been Venom in the past well the suit
has jumped on to a lot of people that's
stupid stories you know that they just
testing in the waters but the video game
2018 showed you Harry uh locked up at
the bottom when you finished the game
you platinumed it yeah you you know
what's
funny I when when uh when you get
stabbed Craven stabs you I'm sitting
here like you know Mary Jane's trying
help you and I'm just noticing the ass
whooping that Craven is hand getting
handed by Harry like every time you pop
up Harry just pops up and it looks like
they give you like half a second where
Craven looks like he's standing in his
own and Harry just like does a summer
song Just beats the [__] out he's like
boom boom bang bang boom bo boom and
then jump off the screen I here look at
like Harry could have ended this like
right here like yeah definitely could
have but remember also at that time he
was still Harry that's the time when he
was Agent
Venom so there's difference right that's
when flash that's when Flash Thompson
was Venom what's the difference between
Agent Venom and Venom and dark suit and
the suit Venom like just plot points um
Agent Venom it just depending on who has
him well yeah it's listen Flash Thompson
had the suit Flash Thompson had got into
a car accident he was crippled he put
the suit on he was able to walk and
stuff like that and he was working for
shield so he became Agent
Venom okay um does venom like to that
suit even matched Agent Venom Suit does
venom ever that's what I'm looking for
does he ever have the same connection
that he has with Peter with anyone else
Eddie Brock Eddie Brock is that like the
main H he died yeah he died for Eddie oh
he died for Eddie
yeah he he sacrificed himself to save
Eddie he went in Fire and Fire kills him
but he went through fire to save Eddie
okay because what I like about this is
like even though I don't know nothing
about like a lot of the Spider-Man
universe I like how they showed Craven
in a very strong way like oh my God
every time CRA
Craven You could argue that Venom was
was definitely like one of the stars of
the show but I feel like Craven did his
thing in this game like every time
Craven showed up Spider Man yeah every
time Craven showed up I was like yo yo
yeah like he let his minions go do his
thing and then when Craven enters the
scene like and he's getting his hunt on
you you saw the remnants of how he
killed uh characters you know um how he
killed the vulture how he killed uh this
guy um when he got scorpion it showed
killing Scorpion and Scorpion stung him
and he took the toxin head on a full
blast of toxin straight to his shoulder
and you saw the toxin running through
his
body and he he still uh broke it off and
then stuck it inside and and and killed
uh scorpion I was like cold blooded this
is the
Craven that if you read Craven's last
hunt this is the the
brutality and and wherewithal Craven
brings
Craven is
is the human peak of a hunter he he has
uh animalistic type senses o on on par
with
Wolverine uh where he can smell taste
and track any animal on the face of this
planet be it an air water or land uh
Craven has agile reflexes like a cat
like a panther uh he has the Striking
ability of a a a king
cobra
um he is he is the best
hunter that you know the Marvel Universe
has seen and and to do that without any
powers and to to achieve the level of uh
notoriety that he does have because
remember he's as rich as Batman
and as vicious as Batman Batman can be
kill people yes that's the difference
between him and Batman you know he's
he's willing to well he's a hunter he
mounts and kills this is what he does
and he was always in search of his
greatest hunt and so when we when when
the game is playing and he saw Venom oh
he saw the symbiot when Harry was
fighting him and all he can say was
beautiful amazing uh go cuz you you're
holding back you're holding back that's
when he was Agent Venom until he he got
a chance to experience Venom when the
symbiot was actually taking
over that's when Craven was at his best
because you know Craven was suffering
from cancer he didn't want to die a
normal death like a regular you know uh
peasant
how he saw he wanted to go out in
glorious battle at the hands of his of
his greatest foe you if you notice like
because if you do some of the side
content which you did all of it some of
the I realize that Craven's doing all
this against his whole family's will oh
no the thing with his family is he
raised them in um an alpha wolf type
environment where the Alpha is always
being challenged by his pups right so
his kids and he has uh I believe Craven
has seven kids I believe he has seven
kids seven boys and then I think there's
one girl I think there's one girl I had
stop reading at that period of time but
after Craven is dead because he dies in
the books his
kids go out to try to fill his shoes and
it's one kid that goes and
systematically starts to kill all the
other ones so it can only be one like
the
Highlanders oh my God just just killing
everyone just to kill everyone kill his
brothers kill his brothers like it's
it's that deep where that's why he was
telling his kid and his one kid like if
you do a couple of the missions like
he's like Dad come back protect me he
said you're too weak go run and hide you
know like the coward that you are you
know and then the other son was like um
why didn't you take me with you or you
was afraid that I will outshine you he
said like you can ever do that that's
why I left you because you're more of a
liability and a hindrance you know so
it's it's you you hear the bickering in
the background and the Family Feud and
then the wife is telling him come back
home because his chemo therapy or
whatever he was taking for the cancer
has run its course and he said we are
done we you know our life together is
over yeah well no he already saw I'm
going to die at the hands of this Beast
because this Beast is going to kill me
he knew Spider-Man wouldn't have the
gumption to kill and he knew Harry
didn't have the gumption to
kill but when he he knew did did you
were you surprised when he showed up
when Venom was his his own person at
that point or did you think he was
already dead at that point no no I know
he was alive yeah and I know I know that
I you had to have that battle all right
we got to talk about this because this
is the highlight of the game to me okay
and what do you think I'm about to say
when he bite his head off no oh the
Spiderman Symbio suit versus Peter oh
versus miles the antivenom yeah no miles
versus the black suit oh okay oh oh
miles clink kicked his ass yeah what's
funny is like the stuff Peter's saying
to he's like he's like who are you
without me you can't even do basic stuff
pretty
much the the the stuff that the suit
says when they're fighting or they're in
conflict is crazy like the banter in
between individuals I would have loved
to be a fly on the wall in those rooms
where they were recording the voice
acting going back and forth the I loved
all the banter I did
I liked when you were what I liked is
like seeing J and J whatever that dude
is and seeing the the podcast talk and
they're always like she's kind of like
in the middle uh you know for Spider-Man
against spider and JJ just hates his ass
like so James Jonah Jameson JJJ James
Jonah Jameson he represents the old
right she represents the new and she
represents the new but if you if you
watch this game this game was a tale of
dualities where you had miles
represented the new and Peter
represented the old and you had that
dichotomy there that was remember miles
had his two friends which was uh gkey
and Haley and Peter had Harry and Mary
Jane you see they all had uh it was just
Duality it was old versus new was both
games brought together even when you
were swinging through the city miles had
his own type of music and Spider-Man had
his own type of music and Miles swung
faster than
Spider-Man obviously since we're talking
about old versus new at the end of the
game they pretty much passed the torch
uh for for oh yeah of course for right
now I do think Peter will be back but I
do think they're probably going to do
like an independent miles game at this
point because it kind of like well miles
is old
uh uh a game solo and then they can
bring it back again yeah so how did you
feel they handled that passing the torch
do you think that was a good pass the
torch or there was no other way other to
do it you know um how he did it you know
he wants to build the foundation back
now that you know Harry is uh where
Harry is uh because they never finished
that you know Harry is back in the back
to tank so you think you think Harry
will be
back probably is the Hob Goblin yeah I
kind of saw that I kind of think his
dad's going to be the Hob Goblin well no
his dad is going to be Green Goblin
Norman Osborne is the Green Goblin he's
going to take the remember when he was
sitting at the computer do you think
Miles will end up fighting the Green
Goblin and not and not Spider-Man well
it be miles first because he made miles
promise remember he said miles promise
me he said I'll promise you I'll take
care of your son remember he said what
did y'all do and that's when they
started referring to him as
Spiderman you know the you know the
Spiderman the Spiderman so he's equal to
blame because he saw a mild and Peter at
the same time there you know when they
was putting Harry inside the ambulance
but if you notice and they they give you
a whole bunch of hints from that point
on Norman Osborne was wearing
green yeah actually you think you saying
that I I I I just now noticed that he
was wearing green the majority of the in
part of the game um when he went to go
see uh Octavius and on on the raft mhm
and he even said get the get the serum
ready like yeah they're clearly
screaming where this is going well when
he was sitting at the computer he had
they he said get the G serum that's the
goblin serum now I don't know which
goblin they're going to go with I don't
know if they're going to go with the
traditional uh Green Goblin where he's
on the glider and the stuff like that or
if they're going to go with the Goblin
from Ultimate Universe because they're
using two different kind of spiders and
they they're pulling from both type of
stories here you know um Aunt May is
dead at this point in time in the comic
books Aunt May didn't die well she did
and he brought her back cuz he made that
one wish and all type of stuff um where
he he he did that with Miss Fisto so
it's it's a whole bunch of stuff there
so we got to close this up because I got
the adct show in like 20 minutes no
problem um what let let's put you on the
spot what is some things that you feel
like they can improve on going forward
definitely don't use the Haley missions
don't use the um the Whatchamacallit uh
Mary Jane missions Mary Jan's Mission
and I actually in some ways I feel like
they they did better by making her like
her sections more action orientated but
I think in terms of lorewise they kind
of spit in the lore's face a little bit
where it's like she's actually handling
people better than the Spider-Man handle
people like she's like is that because
she's not holding back or
you know because she know she's weak and
she's not holding back and Peter's
holding back and and miles is holding
back I don't know I thought they were
stupid I thought they were redundant I
thought they was not necessary but I can
see them as side missions you know if
you can use side mission because don't
do main missions like yeah don't you
don't I mean a Haley mission is a side
mission so I did the Haley Mission you
can skip the puzzles in this game do you
think they should gave the option to
skip those too no okay so do the puzzles
no I'm talking about they give you the
option to skip the puzzles do you think
me the option to
skips no well don't I mean I say don't
put him in the game I don't want him in
the game at all I I feel like you know
we want to play as a superhero it don't
have to be Spider-Man like obviously you
know would be cool is if they make like
a DLC where they're going to probably
something like more maybe green golin
will be in there I don't think so well
it would be cool if like you play a
chapters like Wolverine right before
Wolverine comes out like I don't think
so I think okay so what I think the DLC
is going to be I think the DLC is going
to lean into the little girl that came
to Harry's house that his U Mom that's
another Spider-Man right right right
that's silk apparently cuz I looked it
up
silk has bit was bit by the same spider
that bit Peter
right the same type of spider
but it mutated her a little bit
differently like she has like a super
Spider Sense like yeah yeah so silk silk
is dope oh the fact that they did that
and I think you're gonna get more Rafe
you're gonna get more of rafe and you're
GNA probably get the Cletus Cassidy uh
DLC and Carnage do you think the next
Spider-Man is going to have three all
three of them in
it silk no I think or you think
Spider-Man's gone I think Spider-Man are
going to put him on the back burner
he'll come to save the day later when
miles and silk gets into too much
trouble but I think they really want to
make a silk game I think silk is next
and then you'll probably get spidergwen
at some point in time that'd be cool
well that's uh the only thing I would
actually say is like you know improve a
little bit on on the side missions I
it's just they didn't feel Grand enough
for me man I felt like I just repeating
doing the same no because you didn't
build up to him after you get to the
like the last main on side I don't have
to do a bunch of repeat activities to be
rewarded at the end should have been
built up between these repeat activities
to make me want to know what the hell is
at the end and that that's that that's
my only real you know feedback that and
you know definitely take the Mary Jane
stuff out I get it there's a lot of
people that love that kind of gameplay
but you know build up characters that
people want to play you want to play as
a
superhero uh Silk's coming in you could
place her right like there's plenty of
people where we don't have to place
someone that has a stun gun like yeah
this is true like cat no actually before
we Lo that Catwoman mission was lit that
was the best like mission in the game
well then you should have played the DLC
in Spider-Man I like the thing that's
what I like that thing was crazy you
would you would really like her missions
you know with Hammerhead and all that
other
stuff that that was a really good story
that's what made me really love it even
more the M the maturity that was inside
2018 I thought the maturity was more so
in the 2018
one yeah and uh here recently Sony has
definitely been pulling back on on the
maturity kind of things and it's kind of
disappointed but that's conversation for
a different time but all right you know
that's that's the Spider-Man 2
spoilercast we went on for what almost
50 minutes almost an hour it's about
what we expected yeah uh you know
definitely tune in for the Mario one
we'll probably try to do that sometime
next week I gotta get I gotta get on it
because right now I was trying to play
Allan Wake too yeah I'm not playing that
I know someone else can do that with you
uh so you I'll do that with s yeah so
we'll do that uh I do we do need to get
back on RNR I think we're going to
evolve RNR to something different guys
you know I actually just watched Five
Nights at Freddy I don't know when
King's going to watch it I'm going watch
Five Nights with Freddy tonight um I saw
Jay I saw uh Michael Myers Halloween the
end last night okay you know and we we
we might just start
doing five uh doing um RNR on individual
things like maybe a whole season of
something once the whole Seasons came
out then we'll do individual videos on
individual topics and plus I think if we
do want to you know continue to the RNR
Channel it'll be easier in that
direction anyway so I I appreciate every
for coming through uh you know I hope
you guys enjoyed this uh definitely
catch us this Sunday king gonna be messy
man he gonna be real messy this Sunday
yeah man Rome is burning baby Rome is
burning and I gotta go literally from
this and go straight to the attic show
have fun bro see you guys peace